he's a willing tool of Israel's brutal
propaganda machine
yes basic human
not make sure this video is seen by him
if you're watching this Nas daily I'm
going to see you face to face inshallah
inshallah by the grace of Allah subhah
wa ta'ala the response has been
overwhelming to say the very least
alhamdulillah we've had social media
personalities and respected Scholars sh
from many parts of the Muslim world
promoting the cause we have raised
almost 1.4 million alhamdulillah and we
haven't been sitting idy waiting to hit
our Target of 2 million we have fully
purchased four properties in London
transferred their ownership to the W
after the help of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala none of this would be possible
without your support so we thank you
once again this is our update to
yourselves we encourage you to stay
tuned
for more updates now that the work
alhamdulillah is truly
underway brothers and sisters and dear
friends we are going to be reacting to a
scumbag dirt back sellout the filth of
the filth in my eyes you know what you
don't even need to tell me the person's
name take a guess it's the only one
person fits that criteria at this moment
in
time that's Nas daily how did you know
it just n in that same order it could
only be one person wow that's that's
interesting that's interesting Subhan
Allah I think it's like if you were to
go to Amazon rainforest and use their
lingo they would even even though they
don't even know who he is like if I show
the feces and I said have you seen this
they would be like ah n daily that's
correct I mean I don't know what kind of
Leverage Israel has over him that this
person I mean I want to ask him a
question was he on the EP was he on the
epin Island was he was
he was he there and was he the doormat
that people wiped their feet before
going in and doing the funky stuff
that's the only think that he will serve
because that's exactly what Israel is
doing with him now he was confronted in
Japan ironically out of all places yeah
this dirt bag and brothers and sisters
if you guys are watching this please
make sure this video tag him share it
with him I want him to see this video I
want him to lose sleep because I've got
this I had this last time I had this
urge of confronting someone face to face
with Tommy Robinson and Britain first
and um AI Y and Lauren s i that's when I
had this feel I'm feeling the same
feelings of finding someone like him
yeah are you sure it's not indigestion
no it's not it's well can be because
he's the same as that what comes out but
the point is this I am so eager and I'm
looking for people who can help me track
this guy down nothing that I'm going to
do not legal it's all going to be legal
I want to confront him face to face if
anyone knows that this guy's doing a
meet and greet anywhere I am willing to
travel even if it's Singapore I and I
mean this I'm not joking around if
there's anyone if a group of brothers
can come together and we can work
together I want to call it the task
force yes Nas Down that's what we're
going to call it yeah okay operation Nas
Down n down Force because he's a coward
and he's going he's going to use excuses
it's going to be no for anything you're
not going to need force with that guy
exactly so if there's anyone I'm serious
about this make sure this video is seen
by him if you're watching this Nas daily
I'm going to see you face to face
inshallah inshallah look this this what
happened in Japan and I want you to see
what kind of a dirt bag this guy is and
look at his reaction to genuine people
who are protesting that you are a
flipping Israeli Shield you scum and and
bear in mind before we even start the
video we know how bad it is in Palestine
like it will take 15 years just to
remove the rubble from the from the
bombing that's taken place objectively
even the ninth head of the UN was saying
if you want to see hell on Earth go and
see the children in Gaza and all of this
is happening and today two days ago bro
people are literally being burnt to
death so on the back on the back of all
of this these people have gone to vent
their emotions and surely even if you're
on the other side you should
understanding of what these people are
seeing these traumatic scenes let's see
how he's going to react because his
videos are very jolly and very positive
he's mocking bro he's mocking I would
give a shout out to palestine. in.
Japanese follow them these are the group
of individuals W I salute them they're
the ones who confronted him look at his
reaction bro and see if there's any
remorse in it yeah here we go
how he's going around with the
camera was he
laughing was he touching them
that's incredible a Japanese person is
coming to tell an Israeli Palestinian
[Music]
go
yes this guy
my co
white ass woman touching these people
you know laughing at them you saw the
Indian guy you know very wise Indian guy
who said that you know what I came for
the event however now after seeing him
laugh and encouraging other people to
laugh this is the thing with this fake
positivity unless it's rooted in Dean
and religion it's all surface level and
all of these YouTube gurus you know a
few years down the line they get exposed
and this guy is no less look at him
laughing this is absolute filthy
disgusting behavior and you're seeing
his fans switch as they're there because
no objective person can see something
like this and go you know what this is
normal behavior everybody's seeing
what's going on the least that you can
do I mean you guys just reacted to that
YouTuber even though he was he had this
rant on YouTube but then after he got
the backlash he had some sh
and shame he retracted what he this guy
has absolutely no shame whatever
laughing in in in the face of
Destruction of a woman saying that
children are being evaporated BR he's
taking pictures smiling bro W if I would
I genuinely believe bro I would have
done something crazy bro imagine you
know your people are being massacred and
you're there smiling and he shocked he
goes you why woman what yeah so he's
more shocked like oh I have a right to
speak about this more you scum dirt bag
that woman who's white is not even
Palestinian she's probably not even
Muslim she's a human you are supposed to
be a Muslim Palestinian there's a big
question mark on your religion we don't
know if you're a Muslim or not Muslim
it's crazy how a woman from another
culture in another country understands
this issue better than the person that's
we living in exactly imagine a white
woman in Japan confronting this comeback
of his Humanity his morality and he's
there talking about I'm an is he put his
middle finger up he was like oh I'm an
Israeli first no way you're you're a
scum first bro look is this a middle
finger bro can you can I just show it to
you
yeah he's a willing tool of Israel's
brutal propaganda machine
[Music]
yes your in should be to
Bean on
your yes was that middle finger yes are
you sure yes he you see that dirt bag
don't worry that finger I'm going what
I'm going to do with that finger I hope
look I'm being very serious here guys if
there's anyone I'm being very serious
yeah please I hope he finds what you
going to do with the finger because you
know how it is it bro bro watch what's
good that finger is going to go
somewhere bro you know not show I'm
genuinely serious guys you can contact
me on my Instagram in please if you can
let me know his next meet and greet
please yeah I willing to travel I'm
willing to travel I'm a traveler in this
land like Muslim said yeah okay uh
please let me know in his next meet and
greet and I want to meet this guy face
to face man I want to meet him face to
face in he needs to know just out of
clarification because obviously he's
going to utilize any trick that's in the
book He's not Advocate you're not
advocating for violence I'm not I'm you
want to go and confront him according to
the law of the country 100% 100% I'm a
law abiding citizen I don't do none of
that that's I'm a very peaceful guy
actually very peaceful he's going to see
the peaceful side to me inshallah um on
that note brother and sisters please
make sure wherever he goes there's a
protest wherever it is I would help
organize it to the best of my ability
whever
make sure this dirt bag did you see how
uncomfortable he was he was trying his
best to look cool he was uncomfortable
he was humiliated I mean imagine bro
you're a content creator your fans are
there and you got people protesting
about you bro it looks embarrassing it
was humiliating and he was shoving
putting middle fingers up you can see he
was very uncomfortable with it so may
Allah subhana I make Dua that Allah subh
humiliates this scum I hope Allah subh
humiliates this guy and I'll lift to see
inshallah that's all I'm going to say
inshallah asalam alum any last words bro
yes and remind people where this who
this guy got um um awards from who's it
yeah the was it a I think it was the ADL
who ad these are Israeli Lobby the
Israeli Lobby group not the edl I mean
edl also tried to change their name to
the English and Israeli Defense League
um but uh yeah yeah they changed it back
yeah and then they changed it back but
however with this guy he is very much
entrenched and in bed With the Enemy and
he is somebody that still should not be
you know that Brazen and he should be
humbled yes yes he he's definitely
academically of course yeah he's
definitely in bed and he looks like he's
in the receiving end